[Musique]
alors qui dans cette salle a un complexe
voilà le petit trait physique qui vous
dérange au quotidien le petit truc où
vous vous dites
j'aurais tellement mieux sans
bon tous ceux qui avaient la main
baissée chapeau parce que c'est d'autant
plus compliqué d'être bien dans sa peau
en plein air Instagram TikTok et autres
plateformes
étant de la génération des millenniales
on a déjà un peu l'impression d'être à
la ramasse pour tous les autres on a une
histoire à vous raconter celle de deux
sœurs moi fleur et moi Amélie qui a
trois ans vivait un même combat l'acné
et c'est drôle d'ailleurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est là vous parlez sur
un grand cercle rouge qui nous fait un
peu penser un bouton pour vous raconter
comment est-ce qu'on a réussi à
transformer ce complexe du bouton en
réussite professionnelle
ça c'est Nous Deux en 2019
à l'âge de 25 et 27 ans on a toutes les
deux décidés d'arrêter la pilule
contraceptive et oui en tant que sœur on
fait tout à deux
mais ce qu'on ne vous dit pas c'est
qu'un des effets secondaires fréquents
de l'arrêt de la pilule c'est un rebond
dans l'adolescence
en l'espace de quelques mois nos peaux
se sont transformés et on a redécouvert
les choix de l'acné
on a alors toutes les deux courues chez
le dermatologue et le voyage dans le
temps c'est prolongé on en est ressorti
avec quasi les mêmes prescriptions qu'en
2009 10 ans plus tôt
sauf qu'en disant il s'en est passé des
choses de notre côté avec fleur on a
toutes les deux évolué vers des modes de
consommation plus respectueux de notre
corps de notre peau et de la planète
on ne se retrouvait plus du tout parmi
les solutions proposées on refusait de
recouvrir nos boutons de couches de
maquillage et on avait aucune envie de
retrouver une salle de bain aseptisée ou
la sensorialité et le plaisir était
quasi absent
et surtout on avait envie de comprendre
pourquoi tout d'un coup on avait toute
cette acné
comprendre ce que notre corps avait à
nous dire on sentait qu'il avait quelque
chose à nous dire et cette fois-ci on
voulait l'écouter plutôt de que de
couvrir le problème à coup de crème et
d'antibiotiques
du coup au-delà des questions qu'on se
posait à côté solution il y avait aussi
un vrai chamboulement au niveau de notre
confiance en soi parce que se retrouver
avec toute cette année du jour au
lendemain c'est vraiment pas facile
autant à l'adolescence bah vous avez des
amis qui vivent la même chose c'est
presque un rythme de passage un peu
comme les bagues ou les erreurs de
jugement vestimentaire autant à 25 et 27
ans quand tu
commences un boulot pour une boîte de
cosmétiques compte à positionner en plus
sur la nouvelle gamme anti-acné comme
c'était le cas pour Amélie et que tu as
le visage recouvert de boutons tu
rigoles un peu moins
donc oui on a stressé pour des réunions
on a annulé des dettes on a testé tous
les maquillages possibles et imaginables
pour essayer de camoufler et oui on a
même pleuré des aspirations de voir
encore et toujours de nouveaux boutons
apparaître et là j'ai la chance de dire
on parce que quand même côté timing
c'était assez dingue de vivre ça entre
ça pile au bon moment pile au même
moment
mais c'est ça qui est assez
extraordinaire avec les complexes c'est
qu'en fait c'est hyper fréquent de enfin
que vous complexes ou les vivez rarement
seul et que nous justement comme on
trouvait pas de solution qu'on se posait
toutes ces questions on a commencé à en
parler autour de nous et plus on en a
parlé plus on a réalisé qu'une fois la
barrière du tabou tombé les gens se
confiaient on n'était pas seuls à vivre
les difficultés de l'acné adulte
mais alors comment passer le cap et
faire de ce complexe un projet
entrepreneurial à l'époque avec fleurs
on était toutes les deux en CDI dans des
postes confortables
malgré l'engouement des personnes qui
concernées quand on parlait d'acné dès
lors qu'il fallait en faire un projet de
marque on nous disait les filles vous
savez que c'est un sujet complètement
tabou
et c'est un marché super concurrentiel
ou alors comment êtes-vous sûr que ça
pourra fonctionner
et c'est marrant puisque c'est dans ces
moments de plus gros doute que notre
complexe nous a le plus apporté
certes le marché était concurrentiel
mais en l'espace de 10 ans nous n'avions
pas trouvé de solutions qui répondent à
nos besoins et à nos valeurs
certes le sujet était à bout mais notre
mal-être nous avait poussé à en parler
et c'est en en parlant qu'on a réalisé à
quel point ça faisait du bien d'en
parler à quel point c'était nécessaire
et à la question êtes-vous sûr que ça
fonctionnera non nous n'étions pas 100%
sûr
mais nous savions aussi qu'aucune
solution était 100% sûr 100% efficace
et c'est ce constat qui nous a convaincu
qu'il fallait aller plus loin que des
simples soins contre l'acné en
réunissant les bons experts en apportant
l'approche globale personnalisée et
humaine qui nous avait manqué
notre complexe nous a permis de définir
notre concept et d'y croire
concept défini il a fallu faire le grand
saut en septembre 2019 on quittait nos
emplois pour se dédier à temps plein à
l'aventure skinnen out on a eu la chance
d'obtenir des ruptures conventionnelles
et on a été prise dans un coworking pour
startup qui s'appelle la pépinière 27
qui nous a donné accès à une subvention
publique qu'on appelle la paia merci la
BPI de 30000 euros qui nous a permis de
lancer le projet on s'est d'abord
concentré sur le sur l'offre donc
définir le produit le coaching le site
et puis en mars 2020 en plein premier
confinement on a lancé notre page
Instagram et notre blog
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque les pages
acné positives et même les photos de
gens ayant des boutons étaient quasi
inexistantes en France nous dès le début
on a pris notre courage à deux mains et
on s'est dit allez on met des photos de
nous sans filtre sans retouche sans
maquillage avec nos boutons on voulait
montrer des vrais pots acnéiques on
voulait que notre consommateur mais
aussi que les gens de notre communauté
sachent que ce qui n'est out a été pensé
par deux femmes qui comme ont vécu et
vivent les réalités de l'acné adulte
et un an et demi après enfin après après
un an et demi de développement auprès
d'experts de la santé on a livré nos
premiers produits soutenus par une
communauté de 6000 skinners
aujourd'hui un peu plus de deux ans
après on est hyper fier de dire qu'on a
soulagé la peau d'énormément de
personnes en France et qu'au-delà de ça
on a réussi à rassembler une communauté
de plus de 36 000 personnes qui tous les
jours nous envoient des messages pour
nous remercier de les avoir aidés à
reprendre confiance en eux à décomplexer
un complexe qu'on partageait
alors racontez comme ça ça a peut-être
l'air facile mais la réalité est
beaucoup plus longue et complexe avec
les hauts et les bas classiques de
l'entrepreneuriat mais une chose est
sûre c'est que dans tous les moments de
doute on en revenait à cet instant
initial à ce vécu pour se rebooster se
donner confiance et prendre nos
décisions
aujourd'hui nous n'avons presque plus
d'acné un bouton par-ci par là certes
mais rien à voir avec ce que nous avons
vécu il y a 3 ans
mais aujourd'hui encore nous pouvons
dire que ce complexe a été et est
toujours notre plus grande force dans ce
projet entrepreneurial
c'est aussi et nous en sommes convaincus
ce que cherche et rechercheront les
futurs consommateurs ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne faut pas vendre on peut vendre
mais on se doit de vendre avec
authenticité le consommateur aujourd'hui
ne recherche plus un simple produit il
recherche une histoire et un vécu
qui lui donne confiance et qui fasse
qu'il se retrouve parmi la multidopes
multitude d'offres auxquelles il est
confronté alors oui donc aujourd'hui
nous n'avons presque plus de boutons et
cela soulève la note de fin comment du
coup rester aligné avec nos
consommateurs malgré cette peau apaisée
comment rester le plus proche de notre
complexe pour répondre au mieux à notre
communauté comment leur parler toujours
avec authenticité
c'est notre challenge de cette deuxième
phase de croissance et nous avons hâte
de le relever auprès de notre communauté
et petit mot de fin donc pour tous ceux
qui ont levé la main tout à l'heure on
vous souhaite de réussir à dépasser
votre concept à votre façon et pour ça
on vous encourage à trouver votre
communauté parce qu'on peut vous assurer
que tous les stress que vous avez eu par
rapport à ce complexe toutes les phrases
négatives que vous vous répétez sont
partagés et que c'est aussi en en
parlant à d'autres gens qui partagent ce
complexe qu'on réalise à quel point le
complexe des autres est souvent infondé
et qu'on peut alors se dire parfois
aussi que
nous peut-être que nous aussi on donne
trop d'importance à ce complexe et si
cette communauté n'existe pas on vous
encourage à la créer c'est ça la magie
des réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui en
quelques clics vous pouvez transformer
votre citron en limonade
merci pour votre écoute merci
[Musique]